Now let's look at
the ROC curve so we
can understand the
performance of our model
at different cutoffs.
We'll first need to
load the ROCR package
with a library(ROCR).
Next, we'll build our
ROCR prediction object.
So we'll call this
object predROCR =
prediction(pred.prob,
test$responsive).
All right.
So now we want to
plot the ROC curve
so we'll use the performance
function to extract
the true positive rate
and false positive rate.
So create something
called perfROCR =
performance(predROCR,
"tpr", "fpr").
And then we'll plot(perfROCR,
colorize=TRUE),
so that we can see the colors
for the different cutoff
thresholds.
All right.
Now, of course, the
best cutoff to select
is entirely dependent on the
costs assigned by the decision
maker to false positives
and true positives.
However, again, we
do favor cutoffs
that give us a high sensitivity.
We want to identify a large
number of the responsive
documents.
So something that
might look promising
might be a point
right around here,
in this part of
the curve, where we
have a true positive
rate of around 70%,
meaning that we're
getting about 70%
of all the responsive documents,
and a false positive rate
of about 20%, meaning
that we're making mistakes
and accidentally identifying
as responsive 20%
of the non-responsive documents.
Now, since, typically, the
vast majority of documents
are non-responsive,
operating at this cutoff
would result, perhaps,
in a large decrease
in the amount of
manual effort needed
in the e-discovery process.
And we can see
from the blue color
of the plot at this
particular location
that we're looking at a
threshold around maybe 0.15
or so, significantly lower
than 50%, which is definitely
what we would expect
since we favor
false positives to
false negatives.
So lastly, we can
use the ROCR package
to compute our auc value.
So, again, call the
performance function
with our prediction object, this
time extracting the auc value
and just grabbing the
y value slot of it.
We can see that we have an auc
in the test set of 79.4%, which
means that our model
can differentiate
between a randomly selected
responsive and non-responsive
document about 80% of the time.